all right joining me now is Ohio
Congressman Jim Jordan and New York
Congressman Lee Zeldin congressman
Jordan let's start with you looks like
Steny Hoyer is saying that May 4th will
be when y'all are called back into
session for real as the country is
bleeding jobs obviously continuing loss
of life but things seem to be
stabilizing in most of the country well
I know congressional on the job movement
here while the country is in such peril
no you're exactly right Laura we got all
these task force and they're doing great
work but the task force that's supposed
to be focused on doing the people's work
is the United States Congress and the 50
General Assembly is in the respective
states they're supposed to be meeting
taking care of a business and leading by
example why aren't we meet you know we
can be having hearings we could sit
every other chair we could be Kentucky
the people's business so why won't an SI
plus II quit criticizing the president
and tell us what her plan is for
bringing Congress back into session so
we can lead by example and do the
people's work so I am all for that
my guess is lots of my colleagues are
for that but we haven't heard anything
from Speaker Pelosi and mr. Hoyer other
than they're now saying we're not coming
back until May 4th well I would consider
the freedom caucus and all the other
Republicans no Capitol Hill just to come
back just to come back I mean you can go
into your offices you can hold press
conferences now congressman Zeldin I
want to get you this as congressman
Jordan just mentioned speaker Pelosi now
she's nowhere to be seen she's she's at
Pacific Heights and the San Francisco
Napa Valley I don't know where she is
but she's reeling on president Trump
political reporting tonight that Pelosi
sharply criticized Trump's handling of
the corona virus outbreak telling
Democrats I guess that I called that it
was quote almost sinful how this his
administration has failed to live up to
promises to make testing available to
all American Quinns and quickly and gown
and mass shortage etcetera across the
country so if this is almost sinful
congressman Zeldin what about a Speaker
of the House when Americans are dying
and people in small businesses say
they're dying Congress is not in session
she's apparently not going to pass a
shutdown mandate via legislation right
in the Paycheck protection program that
fund is going to run out of money she
looks at this as leverage to be able to
get unrelated priority items as she
tried the last time with phase three the
green New Deal ballot harvesting another
item some got in you know the twenty
five million dollars for the Kennedy
Center three hundred fifty million
dollars for the refugee assistance that
actually made its way into the bill so
she really likes the the way that gavel
feels in her hand so for her it she has
a look at this as an opportunity to be
bipartisan or nonpartisan she just wants
to expand her majority she wants to take
out the president states and you know
regardless of the consequences for
Americans that need Congress to work
she's just gonna do what's best in her
own political interest by the way she
has people rank-and-file in her own
conference there are people I talked to
they would actually like to work with us
work with the President to get good
things done but unfortunately the leader
of their party doesn't have that same
goal Oh congressman Jordan Joe Biden al
I think alike Pelosi they they
acknowledge the crisis but they see a
political opportunity which has to be
exposed every step of the way
this is what he said on using this for
climate change congressman watch the
United States has no choice but to seize
this opportunity and create millions
millions of great paying jobs that your
energy plan has suggested and mine as
well an energy infrastructure of
tomorrow we take a backseat to no one
when it comes to fighting climate change
we have to seize on this virus as a
political opportunity
imagine if the president said that we
need to seize on this virus as an
opportunity to you know anything they
say they take on China's fun the wall I
mean they'll did jump all over him and
they do two things that Democrats never
missed the Left never misses never miss
an opportunity to use a crisis to
advance their left-wing crazy agenda
they never miss an opportunity to attack
the president they started attacking the
president before he was even elected
president so those are the two things
you can always count on consistently
from the left but
the thing that scares me most more is
what we're seeing happen in civil
liberties fundamental freedom with a god
the Governor of Kentucky say he's gonna
arrest people at church we had we had a
prosecutor in one of our counties say he
was gonna charge people for felonies if
they weren't but they were violating the
shelter at home he even said if he was
governor he would call out the National
Guard and go to stop people from going
to church on Sunday
we got google saying they'll track and
give that information to the government
and the scariest thing of all the
scariest thing of all is Garcetti the
mayor of Los Angeles said if people
snitch they will be rewarded and all
this happening I did that this happens
all this happens at the same time that
Michael Horowitz is telling us when he
looked at the twenty-ninth eyes
allocations every single one of them had
problems when they were spying when they
were looking to go spy on American
citizens that's the context that scares
me the most so that's why Congress also
should be back at work defending civil
liberties and leading by example doing
the will of the people I want to stand
up and applaud that congressman Zeldin
we're thinking of tracking Americans who
have or try having some database which
ultimately could believe to contact
tracing in it some of it sounds may be
plausible but we're talking about to
reopen the country according to some of
the experts we'd need to test six to
seven million people in these various
tests per week I think we're doing what
200,000 that right correct something bit
correct me if I'm wrong but we have to
set metrics for reopening the country
that are realistic not continuing to
move the goalposts on when Americans can
actually exercise their civil liberties
and make a decent darn living our
economy was the strongest that's ever
been before this happened we had
unemployment rates at record lows
we had our markets at record highs and
then it all came to a screeching halt
because this virus that quickly spread
all throughout the entire country I'm
all for reopening our economy smartly
that means we don't want to see another
outbreak part of that is including and
ramping up rapid testing ramping up
antibody testing to be able to obviously
get a vaccine over
congressman I agree with kind of a
holdout we got to go on a second but I
agree with you in an ideal world where
we don't actually have to pay bills and
small businesses don't have to like pay
rent yeah having six or seven million
tests maybe maybe maybe we can do all
that maybe my thinking on this is wrong
maybe but it has to be realistic and
achievable for a virus that ends up a
mortality rate will end up being about
fifty five sixty thousand horrible but
certainly not 2.2 million and we're
gonna then like Keep America closed till
we have seven million tests a day or a
week or whatever the heck the new number
is I mean that's people have to think
about that I mean think about whether
it's even achievable before Election Day
I should say fine geography you should
be not quite RG quick geography should
definitely be part of this I mean I come
from Suffolk County New York well we
have over 21 and a half thousand
positive coronavirus cases bringing back
the economy in a place like mine might
be different than some other parts of
the country that have been less affected
you're right absolutely right and it is
incredibly hard hit there and it's
different from Nebraska or even Ohio
gentlemen great to see you both tonight
thank you so much and I hope Nancy
Pelosi was watching